donc si vous y êtes vous pris avec mon
expérience j'ai bégayé aura t on a trop
compris à vivre l'expérience la plus
étrange du monde sur un jeu vidéo où
j'entendais sur le gameplay c'est le jeu
apparemment le plus celle où de steam
voilà vous les conseillez et c'est
bizarre il faut pas il faut juste mettre
ça là oui c'est bien lucas plug and play
c'est parti il faut cliquer ok très bien
il ya deux doigts qui sera pas envie de
rien je sais pas pourquoi voilà c c'est
quoi cette grande oie faut faire quoi tu
peux les bouger c'est embrasse batwa
serbe à bourg doit au bout c'est fini ok
ok je sors le truc et par celle où
j'adore ça alors qu'est ce vous faire il
faut cliquer et recliquer change de sens
d'accord très intéressant ok tombe à mon
dieu relève toi homme juif un massage
cardiaque
je continue le massage cardiaque alors
qu'il est debout et vivant parce que ça
se soit pas le cas c'est le coup de
quelqu'un allez tu m'auras pas ce petit
jeu là mon gars ok [ __ ] mais pas que
ça va passer
c'est totalement non il sera entouré ont
plus de toi on va le laisser courir va
pas laisser courir
oh mon dieu c'est une petite variante
est apte à courir aux branches au cosec
le bouton ok oh là là on avait tous nos
matches on prend le mec on le fait
avancer
j'ai besoin que ça sur une imagination
en fait que la neige et un écran noir
devant moi et que je parle dans un
délire chelou hockey et on repasse
au-dessus mais l'at-il un sens à la vie
dans ce jeu vidéo allez continuent de
toucher ton copain voilà au tac à la
violence il a tué il a tué le conte
radical tout le monde se frappent
gestion par le pied sur ce bouton tout
et lui s'en va voilà c'est le grand
gagnant finalement
chaque coffret comprend la prison va en
haut à gauche
c'est de la merde on appuie mille fois
sur le bouton c'est la grosse merde on
appuie sur le bouton avec la prise c'est
de l'énorme merde on clique sur le cab
ici il ne se passe rien on vous renvoie
la prison on appuie sur le saut de
[ __ ] de boue à temps mais c'est quoi
ces vieux de farces et attrapes quoi
elle est attendue où là il trônait dans
un magasin qui vend des claques doit d
focac en plastique un nom au bas du cou
à la tâche et à brancher salah est en
taule à la lumière fut et puis guanaco
hockey aux plats aux mondiaux il a
rentré ses piques et et il fait quoi est
ce
non non non non c'est une pièce mais
j'adorerais faire caca des pièces moi et
j'avais quoi jamais dans sa dans son
trou de tête jeu auquel tout le monde
doit jouer dans sa vie c'est une sorte
c'est le brevet des jeux vidéo
finalement tu dois jouer à ce jeu est
vendu à autre chose
h le guide avec le bruit c'est ça c'est
qui ces visuels et c'est une expérience
incroyable vraiment ok on est revenu au
point de départ
aïe ramasse tes pièces essaimé dans les
trous voilà il m'a envoyé un deuxième
petit truc dont j'ai appuyé sur les deux
boutons et c'est la suite ok on recompte
un copain il vaut sans boiter c'est ça
bonjour elle me dit bonjour je dis
bonjour au revoir au revoir et c'est
fini on retombe sur l europe
tu me connais oui je te connais non tu
me connais pas si je te connais non
si si non car cette fois est ce que tu
m'aimes je ne sais pas je t'aime je ne
pense pas que je t'aime je t'aime je
pense que tu ne m'aimes pas fais moi un
câlin je suis pas sûr mais je t'aime moi
non inertes
ça fait mal ça médias ça fait mal et
c'est la fin je m'en vais au haut c'est
horrible ce qui s'est passé pour cet
homme pas pour ce bon c'est
indescriptible
ta gueule approchez-vous l'un de l'autre
ok l'animation et vont faire quoi ils
sont un câlin et là il ne pense qu'à
sortir d'ici non non et alors ensuite il
faut que j'aie des branches voilà hélas
non je suis sur un moment il faut qu'il
va se passer c'est un moment c'est sûr
oh oui [ __ ] à voile à s'arrêter sur
une à l'avoir question d'emboîtage oh là
là et lui du coup il fait comment non
ils se déplacent des services et aux
verts le glaucome mon gars qu'est ce que
c'est à quoi je suis en train de jouer
il y en a un autre qui le rejoint dans
la fête c'est sa [ __ ] mais c'est the
human centipede rouge c'est pourquoi je
vous les gens roulent à leur tête dans
le cul des audois là comme ça ok oh non
mais mec non mes mecs mais qu'est ce que
c'est mais mais c'est incroyable mais je
pensais pas que des gens pouvaient faire
ça il est beau il se jette dans l'anus
de son franchir
les doigts qui vont se toucher c'est la
fin on a fini le jour non ils sont ratés
c'est fait exprès je m'échauffe cette
situation a repêché le loup je dois
tirer son doigt à auquel vous dis pas
cela qu'elle doit
voilà c'est quoi ce bordel
je suis du prochain non mais là non mais
là allez on appuie ces explosions et
c'est la fin césar michael bay est bon
je le dois au crédit qu'elle
l'interrupteur le plus bloquée au plat
on a branché le doigt en alu bois voilà
les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur
paille and play c'était un truc de fou
j'espère que vous avez apprécié cette
douce expérience riche en savoie et en
culture si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
aimer la vidéo c'est incroyable mais
c'est le jeu le qui va le plus retourner
en fait comme une crêpe quoi comme
allait bientôt merci